welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the Mandalorian season 3
episode 5. we're past the halfway point
and the episodes fill with Easter eggs
hidden details and a lot of things that
we need to talk about throughout it
we're going to be recapping the plot
pointing out all the things you might
have missed and also giving out theories
on what's gonna happen in the future
directed by Pete Ramsey you might know
him as being behind Spider-Man into the
spider-verse and he definitely brings a
lot with him in his first trip to a
galaxy far far away and for the last
couple of weeks the Crave team have been
talking about just how much of a
differentiation this episode is from
your typical entry the season has really
been trying new things and just in the
same way we had that big Dr Pershing
episode that everyone loved we now have
something else to talk about will it
divide fans will people enjoy it well
it's Star Wars so probably the former
but we're gonna find out and if you
enjoy the video then please hit the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day we don't another sponsor this week
so in said time for a joke why did the
Mandalorian win the race because he had
the best car come on that was a good one
that was a good one to start the video
anyway if you're still here after that
then last time we saw Bo getting
integrated further into the clan with
her becoming the hunting party leader
and also getting a new sigil along with
the night owl Crest she now wore the
mythosaur showing how she's starting to
align more with the more religious side
of the mandalorians we have many
different aspects in the different Clans
with some believing that the prophecies
will come true while Stillers think it's
a lot of heavy spoiled your pants I
think that bows likely maneuvering her
way to once more become the queen of
Mandalore and we will talk later in the
video about some of the things that the
creative team have said about what's
coming oh shout out to Ryanair he played
Ryan Airy shut the up ryanairy but
he pointed out in his last breakdown
that they've added in a Mandalorian
helmet at the beginning of the Disney
plus Star Wars logo many people thought
this might be Mando but he pointing out
that this is shown in a red light and
this denotes that it's actually a
villain I actually think this might
belong to moff Gideon and Gideon might
even end up in full Mandalorian armor by
the end of the season which is a big
thank you now we could end up attempting
to get the darksaber back and would then
try and Rule Mandalore much in the same
way that dot Maul did anyway that takes
us into chapter 5 which comes in at 43
minutes with the usual 42 minutes of
credits and intros titled the pirate
this is obviously about Captain gorion
and his crew however it could be a
reference to grief who too used to be
one the titles of the entries always
have these double meanings with the
convert potentially talking about
Pershing but it also referenced Kane and
Beau who had changed after seeing the
mythosaur now we begin on Navarro and
start off with a close-up of the
dismantled rg11 foreshadowing some of
the things that happen in this entry
grief overlooks a construction map and
he asks whether elsewhere is which is a
nod to the in-universe tracks that we
use to transport Cargo in Goods the
Kellen on spur hyperlane was one that
existed in the outer rim and allowed
safe travel throughout those parts of
the Galaxy we also know that Navarro is
filled with dragons and the like so it
makes sense that my man would have some
health and safety concerns after seeing
them himself over the planet driven by
the arrival of pirates namely Captain
gorion who's come to collect over what
happened with the Pirates in episode 1.
grief excuses his actions by saying that
Bane shot first which might be a little
nod to the Han's solo Greedo debate
that's been going on for decades in the
galaxy and in case you don't know the
various versions of a new Hub that have
been released over the years all have
had either hanagrido shooting first
because Lucas couldn't decide what to do
he didn't really know how he wanted to
introduce Han and he even added a little
artificial Dodge which makes Han look
like a Jedi however I still personally
rock with the original in which he hit
him first time this makes hands seem
more ruthless than like a badass witch
grief is trying to avoid doing by saying
that vayne shot first went back and
watched the scene and vayne did draw
first though grief managed to get his
gun off quicker meaning hashtag grief
shot first now vayne is another
character who pops up in the century and
the nicto pirate goes running with his
tail between his legs natives of the
planet kinten nikdos are divided into
three subspecies with her being red
green and orange nictos primarily hired
by the hug Clan to be in forces during
the Clone Wars this species has slowly
slaughtered into a life of crime where
they carry out nefarious Deeds across
the Galaxy navane is played by Marty
matulis and he's an underling of Captain
Dorian Shard or as I call him old Greg
anyway gorion is played by nunzo and
Ozzy who you may remember from Game of
Thrones and also Sweet Tooth we don't
know too much about Captain Shard but we
do know that some of his treasure was
used by grief to build the Cantina thus
he's in the pocket of these gangsters
and Pirates and though the guy looks
like a piece of seaweed with a face he's
not gonna draw a line in the sand over
this
a grief says that the planet's under the
protection of the new Republic but we
find out that's a lie no longer
looked after by moth kidding either it's
now an independent Planet which means
that the high magistrates like grief
have to police it themselves he does
bring up the spin with petrolo and this
is potentially named after the spin
inward sector from the outer rim gorion
lapses down saying that the Republic
can't even protect the mid Rim it shows
how useless that the new Republic are
the tiny groups of rebels that we saw in
the original Saga were tasked with
running the entire galaxy whereas in the
past the governments had been able to
lean on the Jedi yeah they're almost
extinct this fractured government was
what allowed the first daughter to rise
up against them as they simply didn't
have the Manpower or resources to
protect the Galaxy like it needed gorion
also talks about how it's not like a
game of sebark which is a card game that
we've seen at numerous points in Star
Wars a little quick Theory
so I was looking at the Mandalorian show
as a whole and I think it would be a
neat little twist if it turned out that
grief cargo was somewhat the villain not
gonna spend ages talking about it but
it's a common pop up on our
episode one breakdown I think that would
be an alright little reveal not sure who
said it but if it was you then make sure
you give yourself a pat on the back like
it's the like button and thanks for all
your support mate well what do you
expect you're my number one subscribe
button we've of course start off as
someone of a villain in the first season
and that also showed that he was willing
to switch sides at a moment's notice of
the situation called for it he's clearly
played his cards right Navarro as well
and navigated his way to the top Pirates
are hated by both the Empire and New
Republic so he could still keep that up
and we know that he's had dealings with
them in the past that's kind of led to
this situation might be a lot of but
yeah I thought it was worth talking
about that comment and also thanking you
for sending it because it was you who
sent it wasn't it exactly you no then
[Music]
time
anyway he tells grief not to hail him
again unless he surrenders and begins to
rain fire down on the location like
thanos's ship in endgame nice little
touch here is that the Droid comes in
calling grief the high magistrate which
grief corrected him about in episode 1
when he didn't use the word hi they send
out a directive and get people to
retreat to the lava Flats which we've
seen pop up at numerous points when we
visit this planet we also see the ivory
dried once more and this is used as a
symbol of wealth and prosperity now
though the new Republic took a lot of
focus in this opening conversation I
wasn't actually expecting us to visit
them like we do in this entry we travel
out to one of their bases and here we
can catch a y-wing whilst an X-Wing
takes off as the y-wing lands we can
also see the tip of an X-Wing in the
bottom left corner and this is covered
with a camo mesh so that it's harder for
bombers to spot this psychedelic music
used and a lot of flashes for me at
least a full metal jacket and Apocalypse
Now not the whole War scenes more the
party Vietnam style scene showing what
life might have been like for soldiers
in the camps everyone is just hanging
out playing the Star Wars equivalent of
pool and just chilling we even seen
elderly woman showing how LAX life is in
the Republic now and that they don't
really need the best of the best of the
best sir they just need people filling
jobs saying that though she must be
pretty fast because in one shot she's
standing with that calamari guy and in
the next shot she sat over at this table
moves faster than a Han Solo and at the
bar we catch Captain Carson now you
might notice that there's a badge on
Captain Carson that has the face of a
Rancor on it I'm guessing this is
possibly connected about Buffet who
ended up riding one at the end of his
solo show we saw on episode 2 how much
Tatooine had changed and it's possible
that under his rule it's become more
connected to the Republic rather than
being the hive of scum and villainy that
it once was he of course helped out on
Navarro and we get a message from Carson
that Rifts on the only Hub one that Leia
sent out to Obi-Wan he's then joined by
lasat and you might recognize his
species as being the same one that Kyle
kestus's Master belonged to in the game
falling order now this is actually a big
Rebels character making their
live-action debut and if you watch their
show then you'll likely recognize this
as Zeb this is confirmed by the credit
and my boy Zeb he's making it a live
action he's killing it TiVo wants to
forward the message to corusand but the
lasat Hammers home the idea of just how
swamp the planet is again the hands are
too tied up in running things that
they're unable to run things from here
he travels to the building that we saw
Dr Pershing working at and we can also
catch Kane working there as a spy still
I love how you can see her spying on the
meeting and you might also notice her
standing behind the glass as they're
chatting away she then enters trying to
put herself forward for it and with her
wanting to do this it makes me think
she's got ulterior motives ajita Navarro
is still being independent the Republic
is pushing them to the back of the queue
he brings up how he heard moth Gideon
didn't make it to the trial and this
builds off the back of the chatter that
the amnesty officers said in episode 3.
now Marth Gideon was first introduced
all the way back in the first season and
though we don't know his entire
backstory we do have some bits about his
early life that we know Gideon was
actually an officer who worked for the
ISB which is an organization that we've
seen in shows like Andor Gideon has had
a major grudge against the mandalorians
for a long time and he actually helped
to carry out the Great Purge that killed
them in their Millions this is also when
he came into possession of the darksaber
having beaten Bo in single combat in 9
ABY he attained the rank of moth and
actually faked an execution for war
crimes that he could fly in the Republic
radar clearly faking his death is semi
that he's done before and with rumors
once more circulating that he never made
it a trial he clearly used something
like this again to escape persecution
leading remnants of the Empire he tasked
the client with getting his hands on
grogu and though we don't know what this
is yet I think I know we have enough at
this point to fill in the blanks that
they were getting Palpatine to somehow
Palpatine returned I think Kane might
secretly be a Triple H in working for
him and she could have punished Pershing
as an act of Revenge for the fact he
betrayed Gideon Pershing was the one who
gave up the moth's location in season
two so this might be a plan for him
later on we find out that he was rescued
by mandalorians and this could have been
done because they saw him as a leader
due to him wielding the darksaber
however due to him carrying out the
purge they may have been wanting to
enact their own Justice and they could
have captured him themselves to subject
him to a fate worse than death like
watching a ryanairy video hey having
that shut the up Ryan Airy to be
fair his videos are are a lot better
than mine to be fair now who who does
number two work for well that's likely
thrawn who will potentially at least be
name dropped in this series again first
mentioned back in the isaka episode in
season 2 her solo series will probably
follow her continuing the hunt for him
the cannon is kind of all over the place
for him as he's a character who was in
The Saga before and after the Disney
acquisition oh well we've actually we've
actually done a full breakdown if you
want to check it out but if you're too
lazy for that then here's the cliff
notes so he's called kivu ronoru which
was on the throne because no one could
be asked spell checking every time they
wrote a novel with the character anyway
he became an officer of the chess
Academy and quickly Rose to the ranks
because of his ruthless and strategic
mind curious about what the rest of the
Galaxy entailed he traveled out to other
parts of space which is where he came
across Anakin Skywalker he added him in
finding Padme one time and he fought
alongside thrawn during several of the
Clone Wars conflicts he also avenge him
at the Emperor who was impressed by the
fact thrawn thought that democracy was a
stupid way to rule and also because he
listened to his story about Darth
Plagueis the Wise for like 45 days in a
row now he also joined the Galactic
Empire and the Royal Imperial Academy
eventually becoming the grand Admiral of
his seventh fleet he saw of control
people like Gideon behind the scenes and
in the wake of its destruction he's used
his pawns to try and gain power however
they can that potentially includes
Mandalore which at this moment is ripe
for the taking Amanda calls together the
group to sell him on the idea that they
need to help grief we of course first
met the children back on Navarro in
episode 1 and this was their home at one
point Mando also brings up the land that
grief offered him in the first episode
of the season and this plot could
potentially become their new place of
residence we of course have many people
wanting to return to Mandalore but I've
banged on about loads of times and
personally I don't think that it's worth
saving now it is important also bear in
mind that those who take the position of
the speaker also have to take the
Armor's hammer and this shows who the
true leader of them is last week she
talked about how the forge was a very
symbolic thing in Mandalorian culture
and how it represented how they
themselves were forged in bescar the
hammer is an important part of this as
well and it allows the best scar to be
molded and crafted a Paz Vizsla
primarily doesn't seem like he wants to
help because his people were killed by
grief who is working with the imps at
the time Paz has very much been your
Iceman in the first Top Gun movie and
he's basically the guy who's part of the
team giving Mando a tough time however
he does the usual thing of being like I
think he's a head mate but he's the only
Ked we've got you son of a
after saving his son pazos they're my
dead and he says that they all need to
mount up and launch an assault on the
planet leads into a brilliant action
planning scene in which they top gun
Maverick the job and also talk about how
they're going to hit things up Once Upon
a Time the mandalorians had to hide out
on Navarro but now they're returning his
heroes in order to save the day now we
see just how tough life has got on the
planet and also revisit a location from
the first season this slit window is
where Mano and Co hid out against Gideon
and I love how we've seen the city at
several States throughout the show now
at a Cantina or a bar or something you
also see several weak way and in
aqualish which is the same species as
Ponda Baba angorian ship we can also
catch in uggernaut as well which is the
same species as quill was the ships are
sent out and these once more look like
r41 Star Chasers it leads to a big
aerial battle with vayne getting
involved basically reminded me a lot of
Star Fox or Lilac was it was called that
in England but but Star Fox in America I
think anyway we had the bad guys talking
trash over the comms and that whilst you
blasted them through the sky and there's
a similar aesthetic use throughout this
pot and the children of the watch drop
in and this is similar how the Death
Watch rescued Dennis a child he also
catch the anzalans again and behind them
you can slightly make out rg11 which
they're still working on as Manda leads
to Fighters away we see the gauntlet
arrive and bow ship massively outmatches
gorians in terms of speed and Firepower
little bit of symbolism here but we can
catch one of the Pirates hiding behind
the stone Stormtrooper helmets that we
used as the base for the ig11 tribute
metaphorically this shows how in the
shadows of the Empire that these Pirates
have risen up all I'm just talking out
my ass again anyway it leads to a big
Courtyard battle with the mandalorians
busting out from the moves that we saw
them practicing on the beach last week
when all seems lost Paz comes in and
uses the minigun giving us a scene that
Echoes the Navarro escape from the first
season there's not too many Easter eggs
in the scene because it's pretty action
heavy but it was very nice seeing
another big Star Wars battle across
Aaron land for a TV show this series is
knocking it out of the park and it's
crazy when you compare the quality of
this to the level we tend to get with
the MCU shows anyway the Pirates place a
mounted gun in grief's office but it
doesn't last too long as the armor
arrives and bests them all that's it um
now there's also been theories floating
around the armor could be revealed to be
root cast this is a Mandalorian warrior
who led the shadow Collective super
Commando group during the Clone Wars
alongside Darth Maul the followers of
maul wore spikes on their helmets and
this is similar to his species which
comes from dathomir this is something
that we also see the armor wearing and
she has the same sort of colors through
cast War during that time now cast would
also be looking for Redemption due to
what she did in her time with Darth Maul
she participated in the siege of
Mandalore against Ahsoka Tano but was
eventually captured by Bo Katan I don't
know if it rules it out her aiding Bo
but it could actually lead to somewhat
fighting redemption in her life anyway
that's in the series time
until the end of times
now vein makes a break for it and I'm
guessing that we're gonna see him again
gordian takes control of the ship and I
love how this sets the wheel similar to
an actual pirate ship he turns the guns
to the town but man don't Bo take him
out before he's able to wreck more Havoc
he comes crashing down at the lava flat
it seems like everything's gonna be okay
grief welcomes them back to the planet
and as magistrate sorry High magistrate
he gives them a large chunk of land I
think that this will likely become where
they settle eventually but the Allure of
Mandalore and the mythosaurs will
probably call them back the armor then
calls bow and we find her at the
underground Forge that we met her at in
the first entry the pair reminisce over
the great Forge of Mandalore and how the
one on Navarro mirrors the larger one on
the planet though that's been lost these
memories of it still remain and they've
been carried on in smaller ways this is
also murdered in the mandalorians
themselves and much in the same way that
the forge can be reclaimed the planet
can be two now the Armor gets better
remove her helmet which as we know
Breaks the Rules first rule of don't
remove your helmet club though is that
you can remove your helmet if this
situation calls for it the armor says
that she believes both saw the middle
soul and though she humored her last
time it's clear that she sees more in
her she realizes that because Bo has
walked Both Worlds that she can unite
them all and show them a new way this is
the way now we've talked about the
history of Mandalore before and how many
Civil Wars have racked the planet the
armor sees bow has been a new way but
this could lead to some infighting again
because we have Manda who wields the
darksaber and he's just got to the point
of being back to square one when it
comes to helmets the thing with the
mandalorians is that they just can't
stop fighting each other and I think the
sides may become divided again with us
having these two leaders now out in
space tiva tracks down a shuttle which
has been repurposed to transport New
Republic prisoners he scans the area and
I love how this little Periscope
detaches from the Astromech droid it
looks over the ship and I think this
might have been an odd to the opening of
aliens which has a similar shot to
what's used here also if just in a 48
minute breakdown on Aliens very in-depth
it's the best breakdown on the film I'm
putting it out there so definitely go
check that out right after this now this
to make a girl one of two ways either
they took him to punish him or he has
his own SEC now following him going back
to our theory about the intro helmet I
think it would be great if Gideon
managed to get some of the exiled
mandalorians to follow him and he may
end up becoming a leader of them that
helmet might belong to him and I think
that would be a really interesting way
to take the character in the future
overall this was a really action-packed
episode especially that last 20 minutes
blew me away but the build up to it was
a bit all over the place you're
constantly jumping back and forth and
I'm not sure the new Republic part of
this show are working all that well
though I enjoyed the Dr Pershing
sections I think when you're spending 15
minutes just going to an officer and
being like can I do this and they're
like no and they're like well I'm gonna
do it anyway it does kind of waste time
a bit but yeah let me know your thoughts
below as is Star Wars and everyone has
their own opinions now as for the leaks
part of the video doing a kind of leak
section because some of the stuff that
we'll talk about has been said by the
people behind the show but there's also
things that are like spoiling stuff if
they're true it might not be but full
spoilers ahead but what could happen
with grogu down the line so if you don't
know Force push that like button on your
way out I'll see you next week you still
here right so we know that Bryce Dallas
Howard will be direct in the next
episode there's also been lots of
interviews from the stunt coordinators
about what could be coming they've said
that man don't Bo have a little dozy doe
which is both physical and also verbal
and this could refer to a number of
things and people have been going back
and forth over whether it's a fight or
if it's floating or both however I'm
leaning more towards it being a fight
with a pair going back and forth over
what the best course to take Mandalore
is both very much his Vengeance in her
heart because of all that she's been
through rasmando's The Reluctant leader
who doesn't really know what to do it
adds this interesting contrast the thing
will make for a potential conflict down
the line now we also have rumors that
Greg who will be getting his own armor
soon and that this will in fact be made
out of ig11 not sure how legit that is
but according to the leaks the Droid
will also act as an in helmet Jarvis
that guides him and gives him points on
what strategies to take in combat so it
sounds a bit weird but it might be good
if they pull it off and that's pretty
much everything that's been said about
what's potentially coming down the line
again yeah take it with a pinch of salt
if grogu doesn't show up in ig-11's
armor mate I don't want to see my thumbs
down suddenly shoot through the roof I'm
telling you this is just what's being
said it's on the internet and yeah let
me know your thoughts below if you if
you stuck around until this part of the
video as always thank you for rocking
with me until this point and hopefully
see you back next week for more
Mandalorian breakdowns we are running a
competition right now giving away the
Superman 4K box set to 3 subscribers on
the 15th of April and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe and
notification stations on and drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the
episode we pick the comments out random
on the 15th and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers good smells to watch then check
out our Brighton and the ending of John
Wick 4 which will be linked on screen
right now brilliant film everyone's
loved it our thoughts fantastic I'll see
you next time you take care yourself
peace